JEN: So on behalf of
Authors at Kirkland,
I just want to thank you
all for taking time out
of your day to join us, and I
also want to welcome our guest,
Katherine Hitchcock to Google.
Katherine is a resident
of the Seattle region.
She's also a UW alumnus, and
she came into the industry
at a very key time.
She started at IBM as
a programmer in 1966,
in what would eventually
become Silicon Valley
that we know and love today.
I'm sure it's a very
different landscape now
than she had experienced
when she started,
but she's the big reason the
way that it's come to be,
and people like her.
She's witnessed that amazing
transformation of the tech
industry, and she has a really
unique perspective and insight.
She'll be sharing
some tales with us
today about her journey.
And she's going to
show us and demonstrate
how she's been paving the way.
And as you saw in the clip,
she's continuing to do that,
and that's amazing.
She's honing the skills
of a new generation,
inspiring more kids
to take up the reins
and contributing to
programs right in her area.
And that's awesome to me.
After the talk,
Katherine will be
happy to take your
questions, and then we'll
have time where she
will do some signing.
Books are available for
purchase over on the table.
They're $5 apiece,
and other than that,
please silence your phones.
At the end, like I
said, we'll have time
to take questions, so hold
on to those if you can.
And without further ado,
I'd like welcome Katherine
Hitchcock.
[APPLAUSE]
KATHERINE HITCHCOCK:
Thank you for inviting me,
and as Jen said, I started
as a computer programmer
50 years ago.
I retired 15 years
ago, and if you
look at when Google started--
maybe 18 years ago--
there's a lot that's
happened since I retired,
and I will tell you
that I have no advantage
over my grandchildren on all
of the new technology that's
coming out.
But what I can tell
you about is what
it was like when I started.
So as Jen said, I graduated from
the University of Washington
in 1966.
I have a bachelor of
science in mathematics,
and I hired on to
IBM in San Jose.
And I want to let
you know what it
was like at IBM 50 years ago,
what was happening and going
on.
I'd like to share with you
a couple of the projects
that I worked on
at the beginning.
And then I'd like to talk to you
about an environmental project
that I worked on.
So when I arrived in 1966
in Santa Clara county,
it was just at that
transition from when
we were using punch
cards to communicate
to computers to when
we were using terminals
and had an
interactive interface.
So the first project that I
worked on was with the punch
card environment, but there was
something else going on there
also, So just 10 years
before I arrived in San Jose,
so that would've been in the
mid-'50s, IBM engineers had
invented the disk drive.
So this is the coded surfaces
spinning at high speed
with the heads floating
over the surface,
just like a
microscope above them.
And if they dipped down and
touched, causing a head crash.
But this technology that was
invented in the early '50s
led to IBM having this
location in south San Jose.
This is where they
built the disk drive.
This is where the
engineers innovated
and added new functions to it.
And this project,
these small number
of engineers who
invented the disk drive,
were continually asked
to stop the project.
In fact, upper management
would come from back east
and cancel the project.
The manager changed
the name of the project
and kept everybody
working on it.
And there's a quote here.
It's a quote, actually,
that I kept on my desk
for a long time, because
I like the sentiment.
It said, "The disk
memory unit, the heart
of today's random
access computer,
is not the logical
outcome of a decision made
by IBM management.
It was developed in
one of our laboratories
as a bootleg project over the
stern warning from management
that the project
had to be dropped
because of budget difficulties.
A handful of men
ignored this warning.
They broke the rules.
They risked their job to
work on a project, a project
that they believed in."
And this was a
quote from Arthur K.
Watson who was the son of Thomas
J. Watson, who was the founder.
So as I said, this
technology led
to the construction of the
IBM Cottle Road location.
And prior to that, this
large piece of property
was a farm with orchards.
The farmhouse still stood
at the edge of the property
across from acres of parking
lots and large manufacturing
buildings.
Inside these manufacturing
buildings, a team of employees
assembled the disk drives
while another team worked
in a special clean room,
a dust-free environment
to coat the magnetic disks.
Another building
offered office space
for engineers who designed
innovations and improvements
and enhancements to
the disk technology.
One building contained a
research lab, and another,
an education center.
This facility was the
headquarters for the disk drive
division of IBM, and it
was the only division
whose headquarters was
not in New York City--
excuse me-- New York state.
And all things were there
when I arrived in 1966.
My workspace was located in
a large open high ceiling
manufacturing building
called Building 5.
And I walked through
a maze of passageways
to my work area, a desk with a
bookshelf attached to the back
to provide privacy.
At the other end of
the building running
batch programs was the
computer, and in order
to submit a batch job
or to pick up my output,
I had to walk the
length of this building
through this labyrinth.
I often thought it was a test.
If you couldn't find your
way through the maze,
you probably were not
smart enough to work here.
My first assignment was to
modify a batch program written
in auto-coder.
It was one of the
many programs involved
in purchasing the
parts and tracking
the parts for manufacturing
the disk drive.
The technical leader
in our department
gave me this assignment,
and when I asked him
about the documentation,
the program lead said,
there is none.
Find out what it does
by reading the code.
I sat at my desk
almost falling asleep
studying this obscure code.
Weeks later, when I
figured everything out,
made my modification, the same
guy gave me the documentation.
I looked at him
dumbfounded, since he
told me there was none.
He said, "I wanted you to learn
that the code is the reality,
not what the
documentation says."
This was my first lesson.
Within a short time, IBM
announced a new programming
language.
It was called PL/I, and of
my colleagues, Burt Swanson,
organized and taught
a class on PL/I,
and I was a student
in that class.
At the end, Burt asked me
to teach the next class.
He indicated that he only
wanted to teach it once
as a way of learning PL/I. So I
taught the series several times
in a row to the newly arriving
programmers in our area.
And then I taught it as part
of the IBM continuing education
program that was offered in the
beautiful new education center.
This was available to
anybody working at IBM along
with other classes, and I taught
it in the evening in addition
to my normal work assignments
for a couple of years.
On this building, there was
a quote from Thomas J Watson,
and it said, "There's no
saturation point to education."
So this education was
open to all employees.
Then I was assigned to work
a mobile computing project,
to design and build an
interactive online purchasing
system to be used by the
IBM manufacturing location.
This was an endeavor
to eliminate
the duplicate efforts, update
to the latest operating
system, which by now was OS 260,
and standardize the purchasing
programs in IBM.
We were redesigning
the purchasing process
from the punch card batch
system to an interactive system
using remote terminals.
Currently, the purchasing
staff relied on weekly computer
runs that printed a
stack of fanfold paper,
giving them the status on
the current information
about the inventory.
They didn't have display
terminals at their desks,
and they did not have the latest
information on the inventory
at their fingertips.
We were creating something
that we hadn't seen before,
and there was no template
that we could copy.
We needed to distinguish
out the necessary steps
for placing a purchase
order, determine
how to store the data
on the disk device,
and design display screens
for the interaction.
But even as I itemized
these different tasks,
I'm looking in hindsight.
At the time, it was a
confusing, unfocused attempt
to figure out what to do.
Many new programmers had
been hired and assigned
to the project, but we were too
inexperienced to make progress,
and I felt it was a waste of
time to teach a programming
language to employees
who were not going
to be using it anytime soon.
I was discouraged,
and I wanted results.
And after months of
struggling on this project,
I decided to look for
another assignment.
So in early January of 1968,
while hiking one weekend
with friends, I reviewed
the working conditions
and debated my options.
By the end of the hike, I had
decided the situation at work
was unacceptable, and
I'd request a transfer.
There weren't publicly
available lists of jobs.
You needed to
request a transfer,
submit it to the
personnel department,
and then they would tell
you if any managers were
looking for a job.
This time, he let
me know that there
was an opening for a programming
position in another IBM
location, which was located
across the valley near Los
Gatos.
Now I mentioned previously
about the disk technology
that led to this large
manufacturing and engineering
offices and education center.
But there was another
result that came out
of that group of engineers
working together,
and their manager,
the one who changed
the name of the project,
[INAUDIBLE] canceled.
This manager's name
was Ray Johnson,
and with the success
of the disk drive,
upper management took
him very seriously.
And the started a new
division within IBM
based on his philosophy,
and this division
had the specific
mission of looking ahead
to see how computers
would be used
in the next seven to 10 years.
This was called the Advanced
Systems Develop Division,
and this was the location that
was looking for a programmer.
I knew that one of my students
in my PL/I class worked there,
and so one day I
asked him, Bob Martin,
if he would stay after class
and tell me about this division,
about ASDD.
He said, with the success
of the disk project,
Ray influenced IBM to
start this new division
based on his philosophy.
And his philosophy, I asked.
To have a place
for people to work
on new ideas for the future.
Ray wanted to hire smart
engineers and programmers,
give them a good working
environment with good support
facilities, and let the
innovation come from them.
This lab had an
excellent model shop,
where they would
build any specialized
piece of electrical
hardware for the project.
And there was an excellent
technical library
that started when they
first arrived in the '50s.
In fact, many of the
engineers and model builders
from that early project
worked at this lab,
including the head librarian.
You're saying the ideas
come from the employees.
I asked, how does that work?
If you have an idea
about how computers
can be used in a
certain area, then you
can propose it to management
and receive funding and staff
for it.
It's a good working place.
There's a lot of
excellent people,
and the projects are dynamic.
It's a great place to work.
So I drove over
for my interview.
And this building,
the ASDD building,
was nestled against
the foothills,
up against the Santa
Cruz Mountains.
It wasn't an innovative design--
a simple one-story building
constructed of
redwood and glass.
And walking from the visitor's
parking lot up a few steps
into the main lobby,
I looked across
at the interior window-lined
courtyard with a fountain.
A plaque on the fountain
quoted Ray Johnson.
"Your first responsibility
is to answer the questions
of your colleagues."
The project with the
opening was for a programmer
for the library
management system.
The librarian, Marjorie Griffin,
who had worked with Ray,
had watched the
development of computers,
and she envisioned
how they could
help run her technical library.
And finally, she convinced
the lab to start a project.
We're not just looking
at Marjorie's library,
but the requirements for
large institutional libraries
like university and
public libraries.
We want to put all
the functions online
with an interactive interface.
He told me that at that time
in the mid-1960s, as computers
were becoming
increasingly available,
the different managers at
university or public libraries
were ordering computers to
solve a particular departmental
problem.
Perhaps they wanted to
automate the ordering process
or the circulation process.
But these systems
were not designed
to interconnect to
one another, and they
were looking at the library
in piecemeal fashion.
This project was to look at
it as an integrated whole.
We have the file system
designed and loaded
with all the information
from index cards
from of Marjorie's
library, I was told.
And now we're ready to
design and implement
the other functions--
the ordering, receiving,
cataloging, searching,
circulation.
Did I want the job?
Well, I had reservations.
At first glance, it seemed
like another example
of a large project trying to
do everything for everyone,
but this project had
several advantages.
For one thing, they were
actually writing programs
and building the system.
For another, the library
and the librarians
were just down the hall, and
we could ask them questions
about how it should work.
And in addition, there were
only about five programmers
working on the project,
so there were fewer people
to coordinate with, and I
decided to take the job.
And thus began the most
productive and satisfying
assignment.
Bob Martin, who was
in my PL/I class,
was the lead programmer
on the project.
It was an interesting,
unusual situation,
where he would give me
programming assignment
during the day for
the library project,
and I would give him
programming for the PL/I class
I was teaching after work.
All the library data for
each book-- author, subject--
was stored in computerized
records on the disk drive.
At this time, disk storage
was very expensive,
and it was not foreseen
how the price would drop.
The file system design minimized
the use of disk storage
and eliminated duplicate data.
He repeatedly said that one
extra byte of data per book
would amount to a million
extra bytes of data
in a million-volume library.
So the attention to saving disk
space was a guiding factor.
With the file system
designed, implemented,
and loaded with real
data, we were soon
displaying the results
of simple searches
on this display terminal.
The display terminal was
a 2260 display terminal.
It had 12 lines of
data for the output.
Each line was 80 bytes
long, and it had one line
at the bottom for input.
Bob explained the
programming environment.
The programming language was
IBM 360 assembler language.
The code was written
in 4K blocks,
and an experimental
multitasking monitor
managed the task switching by
swapping the blocks in and out
of memory.
This experimental
multitasking monitor
was stored on one of the
removable disk packs,
and whenever our project
had dedicated computer time
or testing, we mounted
the disk [INAUDIBLE],
booted up the operating system
with our multitasking monitor
that drove the displays, and
then all the library data
was stored on another
disk pack that
was mounted at the same time.
I enjoyed writing in
assembler language
and fitting all my
instructions into 4K blocks.
I also enjoyed working
with the librarians
as I taught them
the new functions
and features as
they were developed.
They were eager to
use the new system
and very patient with the
crashes that inevitably
occurred with the new system.
They were particularly good
about describing what they were
doing when everything quit.
And that made it easier
to reproduce the problem
and fix it.
John, Bill, and I worked on
the design and implementation
of the ordering system.
We wanted to capture the
information about a book
only once and eliminate
the duplicate typing that
always led to the
possibility of errors.
Currently, the librarians typed
this information over and over
again on the purchase order and
on the multitude of index cards
for the card catalog.
One by one, we implemented
the ordering and receiving
and cataloging functions,
and one by one,
we taught the librarians
how to use them.
Step by step, the
library functions
were being automated into
one integrated system.
There were still more functions
to design and implement.
Periodicals had
different requirements.
Circulation had not
been addressed yet.
In the midst of this designing,
programming, debugging,
testing, and
teaching, we were also
giving demonstrations
on the system,
both to upper management
and to outside visitors.
The librarians from
Stanford University
were our guests one
afternoon, and their eyes
sparkled in recognition
of the advantage
of this online integrated
library system.
Once I gave a demonstration
to the IBM chief scientist.
He sat on my left.
I began my demonstration in
the file system, the searching,
the ordering, and I
had finished only half
of my first explanation when he
interrupted me to say, go on.
This happened
several times, and I
must have had a stark
expression on my face
with each interruption.
Then he paused to say,
I do this to everyone.
Now please go on.
I realized that he'd caught
on very quickly to each idea
and did not need
further explanation.
Probably why he was
the chief scientist.
I started working on an
advanced searching function.
I designed and
implemented a Boolean one.
It was very primitive,
and I wished
for something more
sophisticated,
but I did not have the
vision to design it,
and today, search engines
like you have here at Google
exceed my wildest imagination.
As we finished the
basic functions,
we opened the system
for general use
by scientists and engineers, and
the card catalog and the index
cards became obsolete.
Then the library project
system was canceled.
It was May 9, 1969.
I had been on the
project for over a year,
and I remember the shock
when I learned this.
It was too unbelievable.
We weren't done.
But the political
winds had shifted,
and we had lost our funding.
This was 1969 when we
demonstrated the library
project.
It was many years
before libraries
were automated in the
way that we envisioned,
and it wasn't done by IBM.
But we had built an
interactive application
that modeled how
people could interact
with computers via terminal.
We were well on our way
out of that batch mode
into an interactive way of
working with a computer,
and we were going forward.
Now I'd like to turn to
an environmental project
that I did.
I started a couple, but I'd like
to tell you about one of them.
By now, I lived with
a group of women
in Appleton, which is kind of
in the middle of Silicon Vally.
I worked in the Los
Gatos lab, which
was in the hills in the
south end of the valley,
and so I commuted in a carpool
with a fellow colleague
who was a recent
graduate from Stanford.
And after about an
hour of driving,
we would arrive at the lab.
During this commute, I realized
how many cars on the road
had only one person per car.
I thought people
could share rides
if they only knew other
people who lived near them
and were going the same way.
We figured out how to
write a computer program
to match people coming from
the same area and going to IBM.
It involved putting their
name and home location,
specified its accordance on a
city map on a punched cards.
The cards would
be sorted and then
printed to give each person a
list of people from their area.
I wrote the program
and tested it.
And I went to the IBM
personnel department,
which today would be called
HR, to offer this as a service
to the employees.
I met with the personnel
manager in his office.
It was an office just big
enough for his desk and two
guest chairs, and I sat down.
I've written a computer
program to match people
by where they live, so they can
form carpools to come to work,
I said by way of introduction.
But the personnel manager
wasn't interested.
The way people get
to and from work
is their responsibility, not
IBM's, he said dismissively.
I was flustered.
I had not expected to be met
with this opposition to what I
considered a contribution,
and what could I say?
But IBM is subsidizing people
driving individual cars,
because IBM's paying
a huge amount of money
for parking lots.
He sat across from me and
reached for a cigarette.
Perhaps he was
uncomfortable and had
no respond for my
obviously true observation.
Since he was not going
to be of any help
in promoting the carpool
idea, I said, well, maybe I
could stand out
in the parking lot
and give out information
forms to people
to see how many would be
interested in carpooling.
His hands stopped in
mid-air with the lit match
aiming at his cigarette.
And he looked
directly into my eyes
and said, that would
not be a good idea,
and with chilling firmness.
It was strong enough to stop
me from further discussion,
and I left his office.
I did not realize at the
moment what he was saying,
but I understood later.
I had touched on a
very sensitive nerve.
Any action like
organizing employees
would seem like an
effort to unionize IBM.
My comment about handing
out questionnaires
was too close to organizing
for him to be comfortable.
I returned to my office and
put the computer program,
the stack of cards, on
the corner of my desk.
I had no place to
file it, and I wanted
it to stay in my awareness,
and for months and months,
it sat on my desk,
always reminding me
of what I was trying
to accomplish.
Two year later, when the
1973 oil embargo started,
and gas prices
soared, and people
had to wait in long
lines to purchase fuel,
I received a call from
the personnel manager
asking about my program to
match people for carpools.
And this is when IBM
implemented my carpool program.
A map was posted on the
bulletin board with information
about how to participate.
I never knew how successful it
was in terms of how many people
were matched or how many
carpools were formed,
but for many years, I
continued to see the map posted
on the bulletin board.
About this time, the ASDD
lab, a division of ASDD,
which had that location in
Los Gatos-- and by the way,
it had another location
in Mohansic New York--
IBM terminated the division.
When this happened, it
wasn't a big surprise for me.
I could see that the division
no longer functioned according
to its original vision.
No longer were the
ideas initiated
by engineers and programmers.
Instead, a more
structured management team
dictated projects.
So I as a little bit at a
loss, restless for a change,
and not really sure
what was next for me.
And then one fairly
normal workday
as I was finishing up
my project for the lab,
I attended a late
morning seminar.
I walked into the
auditorium and took a seat.
The speaker,
Jacqueline Wexler, who
was the president of Hunter
College in New York City,
was talking about
change, about how
so many young people
wanted change,
big change and radical change.
This was the early '70s,
and unrest and protests
were on the campus.
Then she spoke about the
realistic steady path
of change, growth, and progress.
As I sat there, and her
presentation flowed over me,
and she was speaking on
some of the same things
I had struggled with-- how
change occurs for people,
for corporations,
and for societies.
I knew there was a luncheon
following the presentation,
and I knew Marjorie
Griffin, the librarian,
had arrange for the speaker.
"Marjorie," I said
as I ran up to her.
"I want to come
to the luncheon."
She looked at her guest
list and shook her head.
I'm sorry.
All the places are taken.
And I turned and walked away,
still excited by the ideas.
I knew some of the
people on the guest list.
The retired founder of
our lab, Ray Johnson,
was attending with his wife.
As I slowly walked back
through the auditorium immersed
in my thoughts, and
then a moment later,
Marjorie stopped me.
Ray's wife couldn't make it.
You can have her
place at the luncheon.
And this all happened so
fast that I could barely
catch my breath.
The next thing I
knew, I was seated
at a long table with
a white tablecloth
and place settings
for 20 people.
I looked around to
locate the speaker.
She sat off to my right down
at the other end of the table,
too far away for me to
be able to talk to her
or even hear her conversation.
I was introduced to the
man sitting on my left.
He was the IBM vice-president.
My first comment to him
was, how do corporations
change if they keep promoting
into management people who
think the same way as
the current managers?
To his credit, he
responded by asking, what
would you like to see changed?
Well, this wasn't going to
be an abstract conversation
about change.
He directed me immediately
to the practical.
Well, I said, I've written
a computer program to match
people so they can
carpool to work,
and when I went to the personnel
department to offer this,
they said it was the employee's
responsibility, not IBM's.
He sidestepped me once
again when he asked,
do you know about
the work that Dr. Pat
Manti is doing in the San
Jose research division?
It's a project involving
geographic database problems,
and no, I didn't.
Well, he said, you
should go talk to him,
and I'll call him and let
him know to expect you.
The result of the luncheon was
an appointment the next day
with Dr. Manti, and here
I learned about the ideas
they were exploring to solve
the class of problems that
required geographical data.
They were looking
at how to organized
the data to facilitate searches
based on location, path,
and direction.
He felt that my idea of
matching people for carpools
was exactly the kind
of geographical problem
they were addressing.
Did I want to come and spend the
summer as an internship working
with them?
And of course, I did.
This led to a summer
working on the GADS project,
and it stood for Geographical
Access Data Storage.
And it was very
early research on how
to store data for sorting and
retrieving geographical data.
I redesigned my carpool
program to use the GADS data
structures.
It was a wonderful
summer of engaging work
with bright,
forward-thinking colleagues.
It didn't result
in any carpools.
But this summer
was my introduction
to working and knowing
about IBM research.
So the IBM San
Jose research lab,
which was located right there
next to the manufacturing
and development of a
disk storage device,
had a focus on projects that
could enhance the disk's
technology, both in terms
of material science research
like the coding material, and
in terms of computer science
research.
Ted Codd, the inventor of the
relational model for database
management, worked here
and wrote his 1970 paper
on relational databases.
And Don Chamberlain
and Raymond Boyce,
who [INAUDIBLE] SQL, or
S-Q-L, as a special purpose
programming language work here.
John Backus, already
named as an IBM fellow
for inventing FORTRAN,
worked here also.
I went on to other projects, but
a few years later, I came back,
and I started working
at the research lab,
and I finished my career
working at the lab.
That building that was on
the San Jose [INAUDIBLE],
they built a new lab on
the hills just adjacent
to that Cottle Road facility,
and the research lab
continues to be a dynamic
environment, an impressive list
of inventions and discoveries
that continue to this day.
And then I'd like to give you a
little bit of a retrospective,
because as I said, I
stopped working In 2001,
but in 2006, I was in San
Jose, and I decided to go back
and have lunch with some of my
colleagues at the IBM Almaden
Research Center.
And I was driving there,
I had a flood of memories
from when I first drove down
that highway 40 years earlier
to interview for a job.
And reflecting on that day,
my senior year at university,
and my subsequent decision
to accept the IBM offer,
I pondered how things
had turned out.
As I continued down the highway,
I turned right at the entrance
to the IBM Cottle Road
site where I first started,
and I was surprised
to see a Hitachi
sign next to the IBM sign.
I noted this and continued
on my way a few more
miles before I turned
up into the foothills
and approached the Almaden lab.
And at the entrance
to this lab, there
were two signs--
IBM and Hitachi.
What did this mean?
I walked into the lobby
of the IBM Almaden lab,
and I saw a large
celebratory display
acknowledging the
50th anniversary
of the random access
disk technology developed
by those engineers.
50 years, I mused to myself.
And I was here 40 years ago,
very close to the beginning.
I left the lobby and walked
down the wide hallway
toward the cafeteria.
Floor to ceiling glass windows
on my right and beautiful
[INAUDIBLE] tile under my feet,
and on the wall to the left
were a row of plaques with
photos and descriptions
of people who had
recently received
IBM outstanding technical
achievement awards or research
division awards, and
I smiled remembering
when I had been a recipient.
In the cafeteria, I
joined my colleagues.
Several of them I had known and
worked with for over 25 years.
At lunch, I asked about
the Hitachi signs,
and I learned that IBM had
sold the magnetic disk drive
disks to Hitachi.
What a surprise.
50 years after its invention, 50
years of continuing innovation
and improvement, IBM no
longer owned the magnetic disk
technology.
I thought about how close
I was to the beginning
since I had started just 10
years after its invention.
I returned to my
car and thought,
the times brought 40 years
of change to me and to IBM.
In retrospect, I used very
little of the math classes
that I studied at the
University of Washington.
Mostly, I used my logic
and problem solving skills.
I liked writing and
debugging programs.
It fit well with my
logical thinking patterns,
and each program was like
a challenging puzzle.
Early in my career, when the
library project was canceled,
and I was struggling with
the challenges of the meaning
of life and on the brink
of a discouraging attitude,
another employee
said to me, you'll
get used to the disappointments
and give up on your ideals.
I wondered when and
if this could happen.
Fortunately, there were several
turning points in my career
and lessons learned
that carried me
onward into exciting and
challenging projects.
I not only found my way
but actively participated
in creating my way
during this time
of rapidly changing technology.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So would you like to
ask any questions?
JEN: We have a mic up
here, and I can come to you
if you want to raise your hand.
I'd be more than happy to.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank you.
So I know from the timeline
of your early career,
it looks to me like you
were working on that library
system very similar to the
time that Doug Englebart had
developed his various
demo of user interactions
with computers using a mouse
and others things like that.
I was wondering if at the
time, if that was something
you were aware of or how
that-- because obviously, ideas
like that were just about to
change the industry really
dramatically.
KATHERINE HITCHCOCK: Yes.
Well, I had the opportunity
of visiting his lab early.
It still would've
been about 1972,
so the library project
was '68 and '69.
But in about 1972, I visited
his lab and the mouse.
And I was quite amazed, but
didn't really see a use of it
for several years afterwards.
But if you look at punching
holes in cards to communicate
to computers,
typing at a terminal
to communicate to
computers, moving a mouse
touching to swiping,
we made a lot of progress.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: First,
one observation--
I was in Peru last
month and dropped
into the library
for some reason,
even though I speak no
Spanish, and there was a card
catalog there, and I
hadn't really thought them
for a very long
time and certainly
hadn't seen one for awhile.
I guess they do still exist.
I ddint' see anybody using
it, so maybe they just
haven't cleared it out yet.
But my question was
in all your stories,
you didn't mention
anything about how
it was being a woman in what
was at that time and still
is largely now a
man's industry, and I
was wondering
what-- you must have
had some problems with
people's attitudes back then.
Any thoughts on that?
KATHERINE HITCHCOCK: Thank
you for your question.
When I hired on in
1966, it was a big year
for hiring new people.
Corporations were hiring a
lot of people, and in my area,
there were four
women programmers
that had been hired.
In fact, I would
say more than that,
because these four
lived near myself,
and my roommate
was a programmer.
And we carpooled together,
so with that environment,
it didn't look unusual to be
a woman in that environment.
I will say that in those
meetings, it was about 5%.
If I looked around the
room and saw how many
men or women there were, maybe
5%, maybe going up to 10%.
I think my focus was on
solving the problems.
If there were
things coming at me,
I just didn't hear
them or see them.
I don't think it was
a conscious effort.
I think it was just the
way I was that I would
be looking at the problems.
I do remember at that time
being kind of mystified,
because there was a
man who had been hired,
and he was working in our area.
And we were told that
he was being groomed
to work at this project and
then on that project and then
on up in the corporation.
And I was like, who's
going to groom me?
There was a project, so I
didn't feel that discrimination
personally.
And I do know that
later on, there
was a time when a
woman in my department,
which might've been 30 people in
the department, was meeting me,
and she came to me, and
she was very upset with me.
And she said, you've
never supported me.
And it was her wanting
that networking of women,
and she felt like I had
not provided that for her.
And I can see in retrospect
where I could've provided
something that I didn't.
And in my view, I was just
really focusing on what
problems that I'm solving.
I do talk about one incident
where I walked into a lab.
The guys were there taking
apart a piece of equipment.
It was a new printer.
It was right after I had
worked on the gas project.
I knew about this printer.
I knew it was a
graphics printer,
and as they were
setting it up, there
was a black line that
came across the printer.
And they were saying, oh,
it must be clicking sound.
And I said, no, there's
light getting in,
because I knew the
printer, and I know
it was a photographic process.
I said that there's
something open,
and it's exposing the
paper, and light is getting
in causing the black line.
And I said this a
couple of times,
and finally they discovered it.
But they didn't discover
it because I said it.
And it was like, well, wish
they would've listened to me.
Does that-- I think I was
kind of oblivious to it,
or maybe that's why
I'm saying "atypical."
If you were looking for
a story about how much
I had to fight for my
rights, it's not my story.
And I hope that other people
will tell it, and in fact,
as I've shared this story,
I've had women come up to me
and say, well, in my physics
class, my physics professor--
I guess it was in high school--
would not give me an A ,
because he had to
give it to the men,
because the men had to support a
family And here was a woman who
just was enthralled with
science and met with that kind
of thing.
And I told her, she
should write her book.
JEN: So in the book, you
talk about the different work
environments that you worked in.
We talked a little bit
about this earlier.
How do you feel thinking
about how the open office
environment and the busy
workplace that you observed
at Google-- what would
that environment be
like for you to work in today?
Would that be
productive for you?
KATHERINE HITCHCOCK:
Well, I have
to say the cafeteria
was very noisy.
But walking through
the workspace,
you didn't have anywhere
near that amount of noise
whatsoever.
For us at that time to
get an office, first
of all, when I worked
at the Los Gatos lab,
we had two people per office.
And actually, I think
I'd like to say something
about my office mate, because
Alice was my office mate there
at one time, and she was
about 15 years older than I
and had a degree in
math from Berkeley.
And she had been working
as a computer programmer.
So I had some models different
people, different women
[INAUDIBLE].
But the desire to have your
own office was very strong.
So we had two-people
offices, and then
when they opened that
Almaden Research Lab,
we had one-person offices.
So to see everything going
back to open is interesting.
I don't know how it is.
You guys have to say how it is
to work in that environment.
JEN: So we've all worked
on that project that
got canceled and put those
hours and hours of time
and tribulation and blood,
sweat, and tears only
to have it canceled or moved
or changed or defragged
or whatever word you want
to use for it, just like you
did with the librarian system.
How did you get through that?
How did you cope through it?
Provide us with some insight.
It's a very difficult
situation to be in.
KATHERINE HITCHCOCK: It was.
It really was.
When you see something that you
think will really contribute,
and you put your heart in it,
it's very hard, very, very hard
to have it canceled.
And there were other projects,
none of them quite as fond
to me as the library project.
It takes time.
I don't know that I
could answer it directly,
but I will tell that
because Los Gatos lab was
an experimental environment,
because they were looking
at showing ideas and proving
them, and in the book
I talk about some of the ideas
that they showed and approved
like the bar code and the ATM
were developed in those labs.
But because it was a lab for
proving things and showing
them, I never really
ended up taking something
all the way to completion,
and by the time
I had started here with the
GADS project or something,
and even just working
on it for a summer,
I never had that sense
of taking something
from the beginning
to completion,
and I realized that-- and I talk
about this later in the book--
that I had developed a
perception that nothing
would ever come of anything.
That was my perception.
And then I realized
how my perception
influenced how I worked.
And there's a very
conscious moment
in this book, where
I make that decision
to change my perception,
where I change it
from a perception
of nothing ever
goes anywhere to I'm going to
work on projects that succeed.
And I had a way of doing that.
I had just attended
a lecture that
talked about how to build
that confidence in people
[INAUDIBLE] solve the problem.
And the thing that's
kind of back to this
is coding, because
if you can see
that you can solve a problem,
well, then, it's like, oh.
Well, I can solve
another problem.
You start to build that
perception in you that I can
solve problems, as opposed
that perception that I had
[INAUDIBLE] problems
that I couldn't.
So I decided to get a project
that was a short project-- not
short by today's terms,
for instance-- and one that
had not many people
and that would succeed.
And I was very fortunate
to get that done,
and then that really
changed my outlook.
And I consciously worked on it.
Instead of having,
oh, nothing's working.
Why should I work such
long hours to the projects
I worked on are
going to succeed.
And that, I would
say, is probably
the major accomplishment
of my career
is to have made that shift.
AUDIENCE: Google's
corporate culture
is kind of [INAUDIBLE]
between this bottom-up
engineering-driven
culture that you
talked about the [INAUDIBLE].
And also kind of like a top-down
management-driven culture, so
[INAUDIBLE].
Have you worked in both
kind of open environments?
Do you have any thoughts on
which strategy seems to work
better for you [INAUDIBLE]?
KATHERINE HITCHCOCK:
Well, I think
there needs to be a place
for both in the organization.
Certainly, if
you've got a product
that you want to get
out in a timely manner,
then you want the whole
team focused on that.
But the place to be able
to bring in the new ideas,
and if you look around,
probably a lot of new ideas
get started in new
companies, maybe
because they can't
survive in an old company.
I don't know.
But I do think that
the corporation needs
to have both of those
and really foster
that environment of ideas
coming from the people.
That's where your brilliance is.
JEN: Thank you so much
for coming, Katherine.
We're really happy
to have you here.
KATHERINE HITCHCOCK:
Thank you, and thank you
all for coming also.
[APPLAUSE]